ladies and gentlemen please welcome
judith bishop good afternoon everybody
welcome back to the plenary session of
the Microsoft faculty summit it's my
great pleasure to introduce to you today
Leslie Lamport who's a principal
researcher at our Microsoft Research
Silicon Valley lab so students and
faculty who have taught operating
systems courses as well as anybody who's
really used a computer will have
benefited from Leslie's work on logical
clocks safety and liveness sequential
consistency and many other parts of
operating systems which laid the basis
for the safe operation of the computers
that we have today as they moved from
the single desktop to the large number
of interconnected devices we have Leslie
before he joined Microsoft was a member
of certain various prestigious
institutions he was at MIT at Brandis
University and at companies such as Dec
Compaq and SR I in his career he has
also received several honorary
doctorates and he has tried very hard to
help scientists see their workers
beautiful and for that purpose he also
developed something that I think you all
know very well which is let ik he's now
going to go on and try and persuade
engineers that there's something else
that is beautiful in life which is
mathematics and that's what he's going
to talk to us about today so ladies and
gentlemen please put your hands together
for this year's am Turing Award winner
Leslie Lamport
Thank You Judith thinking above the code
why do we think well it helps us do most
things like hunting a saber-toothed
tiger or building a house or writing a
program so when should we think well
hunting a saber-toothed tiger we should
think before leaving the cave when the
tiger is charging at you it's a little
late building a house before beginning
construction you don't want to think
about what you're doing when the
Carpenters are putting the roof on
orally start thinking about what you're
doing writing a program we should be
thinking before we start writing any
code how to think when I favorite quotes
is from the cartoonist Guindon
who says writing is nature's way of
letting you know how sloppy your
thinking is to think to really think you
have to write if you're thinking without
writing chances are you're fooling
yourself we're only pretending to think
what to write well
hunting a saber-toothed tiger sorry
writing wasn't invented then which meant
it was a very dangerous activity
building a house well what'd you write
before you build to start building a
house are called blueprints and it's
called drawing blueprints writing a
program well you should also write a
blueprint of your program but blueprints
of programs are what we call
specifications specifications well when
I say the word people tend to panic
this formal stuff that's
possible to read and understand and you
have to learn these funny symbols and
all that sort of stuff yeah this is a
blueprint you know all these complicated
stuff going on but this is also a
blueprint in fact there's an entire
spectrum of blueprints ranging from very
detailed complicated blueprints which
you need if you're building something
that's very big and complicated at the
other end
they're just rough sketch of what you're
building is just something you know
really simple that you're gonna do in
the weekend and there are these ordinary
blueprints for you know things like a
house or the stuff that kinds of
blueprints that most of us might have
seen and similarly there's a spectrum of
specifications there are formal
specifications and on the other end of
the your formal specifications written
in a in a precise formal language and on
the other and they're just short pro
specifications and in the middle are
what I like to call mathematical pros
most code is really simple few sentences
of prose will do some code is subtle it
requires more thought and for that you
have to write it spits prose but it's it
try to be you need to be pretty precise
and some code is either very complex or
very subtle or critical and that's
especially the case if what you're doing
is writing concurrent or distributed
system it is going to be complex and
subtle and quite likely critical and for
that you should have tools you should be
using tools to check it to check your
blueprints
and if you're going to use tools it
means you need a formal language because
tools don't understand prose so how to
write a spec well writing requires
thinking so how to think about programs
we should think about programs like
computer scientists namely like
scientists scientific thinking is a very
successful way of thinking we know all
that it's brought us what science does
is make mathematical models of reality
for example the first very successful
science was astronomy the reality
planets have mountains oceans tides and
weather and all sorts of complicating
things but the simple model that's
gotten astronomy pretty far is to think
of a planet model the planet as a point
mass having position and momentum
computer science the reality consists of
digital systems things like a processor
chip a game console or a computer
executing a program this is what I'll be
talking about computer is executing
programs but what I have to say applies
to all those other things just as well
so models there are lots of models that
you've probably come across Turing
machines partially ordered set of events
you probably haven't run across that and
lots of models but - to my mind stand
out as being the most useful basic
models functions and sequences of states
so functions we model a function of a we
can model a program as a function that
map's an input or to an output or
multiple inputs - or possible inputs to
possible outputs
in math the function is very simple it's
an order as a set of ordered pairs so
for example the square function on
natural numbers it's this set of ordered
pairs this pair 0 0 1 1 2 4 etc and the
element 2 4 is an element of this set of
the fact that the outlet that the pair 2
4 is an element of this square function
is usually expressed by saying square of
2 equals 4 now the domain of of square
the domain of a function are all the
first elements of those pairs so for the
square function the domain is the set
number 0 1 2 & 3 etc also known as the
natural numbers that I like to write as
net suspect to define a function what
you do is you specify its domain so to
specify square we say the domain of
square is equal to the set of Naturals
and for each element X in its domain we
specify what Square map's X to and it
maps the value X to x squared so that
defines the square function now
functions in math are not the same as
functions in programming languages math
is much simpler I'm not a programming
language expert so I don't know what
those things that programming languages
call functions are but I know what math
is that methods are a lot simpler
now the functions model will take you
very far it's very useful but er has
limitations its limitation main
limitation is that it specifies what a
program does but not how it does it so
for example quick sort and bubble sort
compute the same function but they're
very different programs also some
programs don't just map inputs to
outputs
some programs run forever well you know
they may stop before the the Sun
explodes but it's useful to think of
them it's running forever
for example operating systems you can't
specify an operating system as a
function because it doesn't map inputs
to outputs so for that for those
specifications use what I like to call
the standard behavioral model in which a
program execution is represented by a
behavior a behavior is a sequence of
states and a state is an assignment of
values to variables and a program is
modeled by a set of behaviors which
behaviors that represent all possible
executions of the program so for example
let's look at Euclid's algorithm an
algorithm is just an abstract program as
you all undoubtedly know it computes the
greatest common divisor of two natural
of two integers m and n by initializing
X 2m and y2 M and then it keeps
subtracting the smaller from the larger
and when x and y are equal then it stops
because that X and y equals the GCD of M
and n so for M equals 12 and N equals 18
there's just one possible behavior it
starts with a state in which that
assigns 12 to X and 18 to Y and then
subtract the next state is obtained by
subtracting the smaller one from the
larger X from Y so you get reach a state
where x equals 12 and y equals 18 minus
12 or 6 and in the next state you
subtract the smaller which is y from the
larger and you wind up in the state in
which x equals 6 and y equals 6 and
since x and y are equal you stop so it's
very simple algorithm it has just one
possible behavior so how do we describe
a set of behaviors well
first of all there's a theorem that says
any set B of behaviors is the conjunct
the intersection of two sets a set of
behaviors satisfying a safety property
and a set of behaviors satisfying a
liveness property so what our safety and
liveness well I'm not going to bother
going into you know the formal
definitions but a safety property is
false if and only if it can be violated
at some point during the behavior so
partial correctness is an example
partial correctness is violated if the
program stops with the wrong answer so
that's some point in the behavior you
can tell that it that it the property
was violated the point at which the
program stopped with the incorrect
answer the liveness property is one in
which you need to see the complete
behavior in order to know if it's false
or if it's not satisfied by the by the
program classic example is termination
you can't tell that the program hasn't
terminated by looking at any finite
piece of the program you have to look at
the entire behavior to know that it
never terminates so we satisfy specify a
set of behaviors with by specifying a
safety property and aliveness property
now in practice specifying safety just
turns out to be more important because
that's where errors are most likely to
occur and tend to be more subtle I mean
liveness is important just not as
important to safety and so to save time
I'm going to ignore aliveness today and
just talk about safety so how to specify
a safety property we specify it with two
things the set of possible initial
States and the next state relation which
describes all possible successor states
of any state so what language should we
use to write these things well
let's act like scientists what language
do mathema two scientists use and the
language is
mathematics that's the language of
science so the set of initial states
they're described by a formula so in
Euclid's algorithm the set of initial
States we initialize the initial state
is one in which X equals M and y equals
n so that is specified that initial
state is specified by this formula and
the only part this has only one it's
only one possible initial state that
satisfies that formula the next state
relation is also described by a formula
and to describe it I'll use unprimed
variables to talk about the current
state or the first state of the pair and
prime variables we're talking about the
next state so let's look at the next
state relation for Euclid's algorithm
there are two possibilities either X is
greater than Y or Y is greater than X so
that formula is going to be the
disjunction of two of two formulas if X
is greater than Y then the new value of
x x prime is equal to what you get by
subtracting Y from it so it's new value
of x prime is equal to the old value of
X minus the old value of y and the new
value of X of Y is equal to the old
value so that first formula is specified
by all pairs of states satisfying X
greater than Y and in the initial state
in first state X prime equals x minus y
and y prime equals y were okay you
understand what what I said and that
describes one one possibility or the
disjunction of these formulas to the
other case it's or what Y is greater
than X in the first state and the value
of y the new state and the value of y in
the old state minus the value of x in
the old state etc so this simple formula
describes the next state ratio relation
of Euclid's algorithm so let's see how
it works how you get behaviors out of
those two formulas
well for example for an example I'll
take em equal to 12 and N equals 18 so
to get the initial state we look at the
initial predicate s-- predicate and we
substitute 12 for m and 18 for n for
what for n rather and you see you under
that substitution there's only one pair
of values x and y that satisfy this
relation x equals 12 and y equals 18
so to get the next state the second
state we apply the next state look
formula substituting 12 for x and 18 for
y and we do that notice that 12 greater
than 18 is false and 18 greater than 12
is true we'll false and anything is
false so that first half of the formula
is false true in anything is people to
the rest of the formula so this formula
is satisfied by the old value of x being
12 and the new value of x being 18 minus
12 or 6 so this is the only possible
next state that satisfies this next
relation when for the initial state x
equals 12 and y equals 18 okay to find
the next state we do the same thing we
substitute 12 for X and wife and 6 for y
we simplify we see that 6 greater than
12 is false and 12 greater than 6 is
true so the formula simplifies to x
prime equals 12 minus 6 and y prime
equals 6 so it tells us that the only
possible successor state the only
possible third state is x equals 6 and y
equals 6 and to find the next state well
do the same thing we substitute 6 for X
and 6 for y and we see that the entire
formula is false and there are no values
of x prime and y prime which can make
the formula false true
so there is no next state so there's no
next state means the program is stopped
so that's Euclid's algorithm and when we
see special about Euclid's algorithm is
for any values of x and y there are
unique values of x prime and y prime
that make next true there's either one
value or no values so Euclid's algorithm
is deterministic to model their non
determinism we just have a next state
relation that allows multiple next
States for a current state there's
nothing magic you know terribly
difficult you know hard about can about
non determinism multiple assignments of
values to prime variables that make next
true for a single assignment of values
to unprimed variables that's what non
determinism is all about okay what about
formal specs we need formal
specifications only to apply tools we
mathematicians you know before there
were any tools you know wrote math you
know very you know an informal notation
they want to use Mathematica though they
have to you know write in the language
of Mathematica so if we want to apply
tools we need a formal language and the
language that I'm going to describe were
I use is called TLA plus so this this
pair of formulas are written just like
this in TLA plus we need to form a
language we need to write declarations
we declare X m and n to be constants and
x and y to be variables and then add a
little boilerplate we said it extends
the integers the other juice or a
standard module that defines things like
plus and minus and greater than and we
put them inside of a module which I've
called module Euclid and that's a TL A+
specification of Euclid's algorithm and
this is what it looks like in SK now you
can model check TLA plus specs know
model checking conceptually checks all
possible
oceans of the program on a very small
model it's extremely effective and quite
easy to do you know you basically tell
the model checker what the model is
models are usually you know
instantiating values of constants so for
Euclid's algorithm we'd have to tell it
what m and n equals and then the model
checker will go through and in you know
a few nanoseconds for something that
simple will we'll check whoa b1 possible
their behavior and you can write formal
correctness proofs and check them
mechanically in ela you know write the
proofs in ela plus and we have a theorem
prover that can check the proofs and
that's hard work and well all this is
math stuff we know he's you know it's
really very well nice and pretty and
stuff but we know that math works only
for toy examples to model real system
you need a real language with types
procedures objects and all of that ma'am
wrong let me quote something written by
Chris Newcomb as an Amazon engineer said
we have used TL A+ on 10 large complex
real-world systems in every case TL A+
has added significant value either
preventing subtle serious bugs from
reaching production or giving us enough
understanding and confidence to make
aggressive performance optimizations
without sacrificing correctness one of
the other things people will tell you
about formal methods is oh if you use a
formal method you're really going to
kill your performance well in fact it's
just the opposite and the other thing
they'll tell you is Oh management will
never let us do it
well management at Amazon and now
encouraging teams to write TL a-plus
specs and in annual planning managers
are allocating engineering time to use
two
Plus this was written in 2013 I think
there are a few more systems that
they've been specifying since then the
xbox360 memory system a Chuck Thacker
had an intern right at ela plus spec of
the Xbox memory system and just writing
the spec didn't even get to point of
model checking it
he caught a bug that the designers of
the memory system at IBM after
scratching their heads looking at it
said yeah that was a bug and that would
not have been caught by their testing
procedures and that bug would have
caused every Xbox in the world to crash
after four hours of use you can learn
about TLA plus on the web today
I'm not going to be talking about TLA
plus I'm going to be talking about
informal specifications and I'll start
with an example TLA Tech which is the
pretty printer for TL A+ here is what
somebody user TL A+ user might write
some silly formula like this and if you
just did the naive output you know just
you know took things from you know
teletype font and put them into you know
translated the ascii into the symbols
left / right / into the conjunction
symbol and you get something like that
formula and the right but alignment is
actually has significance in TL a-plus
and the user undoubtedly wanted he
certainly wanted the left conjunction
symbols aligned because the formula
might mean something different otherwise
and he also probably wanted those equal
signs aligned so this is the right
output that the pretty partition produce
for this example on the other hand if
you look at this input this is what the
naive output would be like and the user
probably didn't want those two symbols
aligned that was probably just an
accidental
so in this case the naive output is the
correct output that's what you want well
there's no precise definition of correct
alignment correctness means what the
user wants and there's no way of
formally specifying what the user wants
so obviously if we can specify
correctness specification what good can
specification we need to specify
correctness what could how can we use
specification well we can not knowing
what a program should do doesn't mean
you don't have to think you just do this
code it means you have to think a lot
harder which means that that's what a
spec is even more important when you
don't know what the program is supposed
to do and it seems impossible to even
say what it should do because it has to
do something and you have to decide what
it should do so that requires a lot of
thinking which requires writing so what
did I do
well my spec consisted of six rules plus
definitions and these are in informal
met you know quote mathematical prose
and formal if they're written in
comments oh here's an example of one of
the rules it says a left comment token
is left comment aligned with its
covering token well I don't even know
what that means anymore I'd have to read
the spec but left comment aligned and
covering token are terms that were
defined in the in this specification I
wrote and if you look at it this is
really mathematical prose what did I
write this spec well it was a lot easier
to understand and debug six rules than
850 lines of code probably would have
been more than 850 lines of code if I
hadn't written those rules first and I
did a lot of debugging of the rules you
know you write a bunch of rules and you
know what they're going to do is not
obvious and you try a bunch of examples
and I
a debugging code so I could see what
rules were being applied and we don't
would do with something weird and I say
oh and that rule needs to be modified
for this and an iterative process and
the few bugs and implementing the rules
were easy to catch though there was no
problem
had I just written the code it would
have taken me much longer to just get
something I could live with and I'm sure
the results wouldn't have produced
formatting nearly as good so why not a
formal spec why didn't I write at tli +
spec well several reasons first of all
getting it right was not that important
the world is not going to come crashing
down if something isn't quite properly
aligned and pretty printing in
particular it didn't have to work in all
corner cases yes No you know there's no
way of getting it you know totally right
and just as important there aren't any
tools that could help me the model
checker wouldn't have helped in this
example because you know you need some
some properties to check it against and
you know they're just tools were not you
know the TLA plus tools are not designed
for that kind of problems so what's
typical about this spec the spec is at a
higher level than the code it could have
been implemented in any language no
method or tool none of the fate none of
your favorite ways of you know
programming methodologies would have
been worth a damn here they would not
have helped me write the spec because no
method of writing you know better code
would have made the spec unnecessary I
had to write the spec it was not code
and it says nothing about how to write
the code you could implement my spec in
any language you write a spec to help
you think about the problem before you
think about the code
so what's not typical about this spec
it's quite subtle
remember I said 95% of code people write
requires less thought and you know
simpler shorter specs good enough also
it's a set of rules a set of rules or
requirements or axioms is usually a bad
spec because it's really hard to
understand it turns out that that was a
good match for this particular problem
which says you know there are no
universal rules about you know how to
write specs you know no universal rules
that'll tell you how to write any
program in the world
so specifying how to compute a function
specifying what the pretty printer
should do is hard implementing the spec
was easy specifying what a sorting
program should do is easy figuring out
how to implement it efficiently is hard
at least if nobody has showed you how it
requires thinking which requires writing
a specification so I'll give you an
example of a specification for quicksort
probably you all seen quicksort
quicksort is written by Tony Hoare it's
a divide-and-conquer algorithm for
sorting an array call it a zero to a n
minus one and for simplicity I'll assume
that's an array of numbers and it uses a
partition procedure you give it two
arguments low and high and what that
procedure does is it chooses a pivot
point pivot number in low to high minus
1 and then it permutes the elements to
the left of the pivot a low to a high at
it permutes the number the the part of
the array within the limit from low to
high
so that everything from pivot downwards
is becomes is less than or equal to
everything from pivot plus 1 upwards so
fortunately if well seen quits
before so i rambling description isn't
necessary and for this example I don't
care how this procedure is implemented
of course that's the real trick of
quicksort implementing that but you know
I only have 50 minutes here so so let's
specify quicksort and pseudocode you
know this by the partition procedure is
pick a pivot and low-to-high -1 and
permute a low to a high to make bla bla
bla and return the value pivot and you
have a recursive procedure q s applied
to low to high
and if low is less than high you call
the protection procedure for on low and
high and then you recursively call the
procedure for the 2 subintervals and if
low is not less than high then it means
you have one element and there's nothing
to sort and so you're done and the main
program just implies Q s to the entire
array from Sirte and minus one so
informal no formal syntax no
declarations pseudocode it's it's a fine
specification yeah when you're gonna
code you know pretty trivial to code
from this and you know any programming
language easy to understand but it's a
really quick sort it's the way quicksort
is almost always described but recursion
is not a form fundamental part of
quicksort it's just one way of
implementing divide and conquer now
here's a problem and in fact it's
probably not the best way if you want to
execute this on multiple cores so here's
a problem give to your friends and
colleagues write a non recursive version
of quicksort almost no one can do it in
ten minutes they try to compile the
recursive version and nobody can get
almost nobody can get that right and ten
minutes standing on their feet but I'll
tell you you know what the real solution
is
we do is maintain a set u of index
ranges on which partition needs to be
called initially u equals contain is a
set containing a single index range from
zero and minus one represented by this
pair now we can write this in pseudocode
but let's be scientists let's write an
it and next directly in mathematics
so the initial predicate says a is equal
to any array of numbers of length n and
u is equal to the set consisting of that
single element yep this is in formal
mathematics but it's informal you know
we could write some formal way of
describing the set of a on any array of
numbers of length N and before writing
next let me make a definition let me
define partitions of B pivot low high
it's the set of arrays obtained from B
by permuting the load to be high with
pivot point pivot in other words it's
the set of all values that the partition
procedure the set of all new values of a
that the partition procedure is allowed
to return if it's also returning pivot
as the pivot point and I won't bother
writing it out precisely so next
remember it's going to be a relation
between the old values of a of U and the
new values a prime and u Prime so let's
write it first of all we're gonna stop
if u is the empty set so the next state
relation says U is not equal to the
empty set and so performing there's
going to be false if u is the empty set
then we pick any pair BT in U and if B
is not equal to T then we pick any point
P any number P lying in B to t minus 1
and we let a prime be any element of
the set of legal partitions you know the
results of the partition function that
if you've given it B and T is the input
and it returns P as the partition as the
pivot point and then u prime is a set u
we're finished with the remai element
bTW so we move that from the set and
then we add the 2 subintervals be P and
you know to be and P plus 1 to T into
the set u of of ranges that still need
to be sorted otherwise if B is not e is
equal to T then there's nothing to do we
leave a prime unchanged and we let u
prime equal u with BT removed we just
take BT out of out of the set and that's
the next state relation that describes a
very nice way of doing quicksort
iterative iteratively it's actually a
more general algorithm because if you
look at all the behaviors that can
produce the set of behaviors produced by
the recursive version is a sub set that
is the set of all sequences of values
that a assumes is going to be a subset
of the ones that this next state
relation allows so why can almost no one
find this version of quicksort because
people's minds are stuck in code they
haven't thought learn to think at a
higher level than the code now it's easy
to write this as a precise formula pick
any arbitrary value is really
existential quantification the formula
is true if there exists a value B T and
you
similarly there and just let letting a
prime be any element of this set well
that's easy enough to write
is a prime and an element of that and
those relations new values of U prime
those thinks the with pros to the right
of the equal sign they're easy to
express whoops this way and so on then
so what you have is a TL a plus formula
here perfectly formal if you prefer
pseudocode we have plus Cal it looks
like a toy programming language and the
algorithm in fact appears in a comment
and tij plus module but an expression
can be any TL a plus expression it also
has some constructs for non determinism
but the fact that it can be any TL a an
expression can be any TL a plus
expression which means any expression of
mathematics makes it enormous ly
powerful more more expressive than
anything any programming language has
designer has ever dreamed of and it gets
compiled to an easy-to-understand TL
a-plus spec and in fact I regularly
write things in plus cow and then when
I'm proving the correctness of them I
reason directly about the TLA plus
specification and you like the TLA plus
tools the model checker and theorem
prover to the plus to the translation
programs that run forever have been
talking about programs that compute a
function programs that run forever
usually involve concurrency things like
operating systems distributed systems
few people can get them right by just
thinking and writing I'm not one of them
we need tools to check what we're doing
the reason the TLA plus was so useful to
the Amazon engineers is because the
model checker so for concurrent and
distributed systems you need to write
something you use TLA plus or plus Cal
it was designed for distributed systems
it's great and you're not gonna get it
you know distributed concurrent
algorithm right if you don't model check
it it's spent you don't write a
specification and check it the other 95%
really simple stuff here is an example
of a spec you know that I write wrote in
a program why did I write that spec to
be sure I knew what the code should do
before writing it without writing aspect
I only thought it was obvious what it
should do I had to write the spec to be
sure it was really as simple and as
obvious as I thought it was and later I
didn't have to read the code to know
what that piece of code I wrote did I
just wrote the specification could rig
the specification so a general rule
that's one rule at least we can say
about specs in general if you're writing
a spec of what a code should do what a
piece of code should do that should say
everything that anyone needs to know to
use the code how the code worked in the
example I've just showed was just too
simple to require a spec I mean it was
it turned out to be harder than I
thought I would have discovered that
when I started coding and I would have
stopped coding and wrote and written a
specification so what programmers should
know about thinking what everyone should
know about thinking
everyone thinks they think but if you
don't write down your thoughts you're
fooling yourself what programmers should
know about thinking is that you should
think before you code which means you
should write before you code a spec is
simply what you write before coating so
what coach you know what do I mean by
code what should you specify basically
any piece of code that someone else
might want to use or modifying and that
somebody else is likely to be you in a
month when you've forgotten what this
piece of code you've written does it
could be an entire program or system a
class a method just a tricky piece of
code inside of a method what should you
specify about the code what it does
which means everything anyone needs to
know to use it and perhaps how it does
it if it's complicated subtle you need
to think hard about in order to get it
right this is you know what's sometimes
called an algorithm or a high-level
design how should you think about or
specify your code above the code level
in terms of states and behaviors or
functions for input output relations
should do it mathematically as
rigorously informally as is necessary
you should be thinking mathematically
even if you're writing thing the
mathematics very informally perhaps with
pseudocode or pass or plus Cal if you're
specifying how something does it so how
do you learn to write specs by writing
formal specs even if you don't even if
you never need to write a completely
formal spec in your life learning to
write formal specs will really help you
learn to write the informal specs that
you need to write
you learn to write programs by writing
them running them and correcting your
errors you can learn to write formal
specs by writing them running them with
a model checker and correcting your
errors now TL A+ may not be the best
language for you you know it's I'm sure
it's not the best language for formal
language for every kind of specification
in the world no language can be it may
not be the best form of language you
know for what your particular needs are
but I do know that it's great for
learning to think mathematically so
unless you can find something better for
doing that you know which works use TL a
plus you know learn TL a plus learn to
think mathematically how do you connect
the spec to the code well you have
comments connecting mathematical
concepts and their implementation for
example the mathematical concept might
be a graph and the implementation would
be an array of node objects and an array
of link objects in this connection the
other specification especially if it's
an informal specification should be in
the comments and so should the
explanation of how those mathematical
comments are implemented in the code so
what about coding I mean we're programs
involve writing code you have to write
code I have nothing to say about writing
code nothing I said implies anything you
still have to think while you code which
means you have to write while you're
coding but what you're right while
you're coding is is code and I have
nothing to say about how you should code
use any programming language you want
any programming methodology you still
you're still going to have to test and
debug your program not this good writing
aspect is we're going to catch coding
errors because it's not about coding
it'll catch algorithm errors writing
specs is an additional step and it may
save time by catching errors early when
they're easier to correct no promises
there it certainly will improve you
programming so you'll be writing better
programs
why are programmers reluctant to write
specs
well writing is hard writing is hard in
fact because thinking is hard you know
there's no Royal Road to mathematics as
who wasn't who said that Archimedes I
think why is writing hard
well because writing requires thinking
and thinking is hard and as I said it's
easier to think you're thinking writing
is a lot like running unless you do it
slower you are and you have to
strengthen your writing muscles you know
just like you have to strengthen your
rust and you're running muscles it takes
practice and it's easier to find an
excuse not to and one of the nicest
excuses well what if the spec is wrong
maybe you made a mistake in the spec
maybe the requirements change where some
enhancement is needed in fact and the
code will have to be changed maybe even
before the program is finished in fact
changing the code is something that
eventually happens to all useful
programs if your program is useful it's
gonna have users the users are going to
find things extra things they want of it
the things that don't work the way you
know you thought was a good idea be your
customers you know decide otherwise this
happens eventually happens to all useful
programs in an ideal world you'd write a
new spec and then you know the code
you'd completely rewrite the span of the
spec well we all know this isn't gonna
happen in the real world the code is
patched and if you're lucky the spec is
updated well if this is inevitable why
bother writing specs in the first place
if you know this little lovely thing is
you know the spec turns out you know -
has to be changed and you know we're
back in our old messy world well there's
two reasons the first reason is that
whoever has to modify the code will be
eternally grateful for every word or
formula of specification that you write
and whoever maybe you believe me I've
you've done that you know coming back
and don't have time for second stories
but particularly you know modifications
and the pretty print or in fact and
that's why you should update the spec
when you change the code the second
reason is that every time code is
patched it becomes a little uglier
harder to understand and harder to
maintain and if you but if you don't
start with a spec every piece of code
you write is a patch which means the
program starts out from the beginning
being ugly hard to understand and hard
to maintain and then God help you when
you do have to maintain you know try to
unfit out what it's doing in order to to
make changes as Dwight Eisenhower said
no battle was ever won according to plan
but no battle was ever won with that one
so some people will tell you that
writing specs is a waste of time
in some situations and maybe sometimes
there's no need to think about what
you're doing maybe something is really
so trivial that you know doesn't need
much thought but we'll remember when
they're telling you not to write a spec
they're telling really telling you not
to think and you know faking is a really
good idea and don't trust anybody who
tells you not to do it thinking doesn't
guarantee that you won't make mistakes
but not thinking generally guarantees
that you will find out more about TLA
plus go to my home page and click on the
link to the TLA web page thank you
[Applause]
I think there's time for a few questions
very few I think one yeah yes I hope
that's not a judgment on my talk thanks
for your talk
how about specification by example it's
a pragmatic approach that is a little
bit inspired by test-driven development
which since it's not complete of course
but since completeness anyway is
undecidable it's a good pragmatic
approach so do you know so terrible
pragmatic approach it's maybe a good
maybe a good way to explain what
something examples are great to explain
them but they're terrible they keep you
from thinking you think in terms of
these particular examples the real
problem in programming is not to think
of your the easy cases the obvious cases
the nice case if the hard cases and you
don't get that with examples and boy
I'll tell you I you to eclipse
programming and I've you know there's so
much so many methods of eclipse that are
explained by here's an here's an example
of code using it and I have yet to
manage to use those methods to do it
what I want to do because it doesn't
work I find that it just doesn't work on
anything other than that example and I
have no idea why not not a program you
know programming by example I don't know
about you know if that works but a
specification by example it doesn't
thank you for the great talk um so what
happens once you patch the code do you
suggest keeping the old specs around or
do you just get rid of him like does it
help to have context well first of all I
think whenever I well whenever I do fix
bugs and that may require changing the
spec I will also take a note as to why I
change the spec because you know two
years later I'm going to come back and
say why did I do that about whether you
know to what extent that's useful for
the specification itself I don't know
certainly you're always a good idea not
to throw anything away you know we
shouldn't be throwing you know
information away these days you know it
doesn't cost anything to save it so you
should certainly save the old specs
whether you should you know whether you
should mention the change in the in the
new spec I don't I don't have any any
good answer to that without wanting to
be rude or anything I think most
programmers don't use formal
specifications anymore my PhD was in
that background most programmers these
days they take algorithms they take code
they adapt it to what they want to do
and that's 99 percent is from my
perspective how most software is built
these days that we actually really be
nice if it if that where it can build
Bell built well that way
it doesn't work because they're trying
to use I find that it doesn't work
because the other pieces of code that I
want to use don't have specifications so
I really can't use them very well I do
the best I can and I wind up having to
spend a hell of a lot of time trying to
figure out what this piece of code does
which something I shouldn't have to do
if it had been specified
again I've said that you know 95% of
programming you know requires very
little specification and you know a few
lines you know are usually enough but
you know you are going to come up with
this 5% which isn't just you know take
this thing and put it here and combine
it with this thing there's gonna be
something some things code you're gonna
have to write that is subtle it has some
some a bit of difficulty in it and you
want to be able to you know you want to
be prepared for that
because we use the same techniques that
you use you're the same lack of thought
that you use when you're doing that
other 95% you're gonna screw up badly
unfortunately I have never really looked
into TLA plus but having studied
temporal logic it is inevitable to to
fail to to notice that that there's a
lot of temporal logic going on
underlying what you've been saying so I
was wondering have you studied probably
you have the possibilities for using
more directly the language of temporal
logic will future operates as necessity
operators and all that stuff and so ok
TLA stands for the temporal logic of
actions temporal logic is evil I can
tell you explain why because it's very
hard to use but it turns out it's a
necessary evil temporal logic turns out
to be the best way of thinking about
liveness and so if you use TLA plus when
you get to the liveness part you're
going to be using temporal logic and be
aware of it but remember that I said
that safety is more important and it
turns out that you do not need to think
you got not need to know temporal logic
in order to handle safety and what the
reason I think you know that TL A+ is
better than
other kinds of temporal logic is that
you know ascent need-to-know essentially
no temporal logic to use it for safety
if you look at the actual specification
there is the specific the tli
specification I've noticed I've written
it it's two formulas in it and next well
TLA allows you to combine them into a
single temporal logic formula which you
you know you do at the end eventually
and but the idea of the thing it makes
it great is that you'll write a thousand
line specification 999 lines are going
to be ordinary math initial predicate
next state relation and then the last
line is going to be a temporal logic
formula so okay well do we have no so we
are now at the end of our plenary
session and I'd like to thank you very
much but before we do that just to
remind you all we got the buses outside
to go out to the dinner tonight take
your bags with you there will be space
there for your bags and then we'll be
going back to the hotels or coming back
here and now
thank you very much Leslie
[Applause]